[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing anime guy
witches and wizards with the unique
ability to transform into an animal and
back again at will a single witch or
wizard who possesses this ability is
known as an animagus the practice of
becoming an animakus and transforming
your body in this way is considered to
be a specialized form of transfiguration
a branch of magic focused on changing
the form and appearance of objects
creatures and people Transfiguration
encompasses a wide range of magical
spells and techniques from simple object
transformations to more complex human
Transfiguration animagus is a
combination of the word animal and the
Greek word Magus meaning animal wizard
once a witch or wizard masts has the
ability to become an animagus they will
adopt an animal form that is closely
linked to their personality and inner
traits one very important thing to note
is that your animagus form is not
something you can choose it's entirely
out of your control and is left entirely
up to fate whatever you are destined to
be is what you're stuck with sometimes
this works against you like Peter
Pettigrew who transforms into a rat and
sometimes it works in your favor like
James Potter transforming into a stag
it's also worth mentioning that there is
a distinct relationship between your
animagus form and your Patronus form if
you know what your spirit animal is then
it's likely that you'll have insight
into what your animagus would be if you
took the time to master the ability
there don't seem to be many limitations
with regards to what an animagus can
actually be as we've seen witches and
wizards transform into both regular and
magical creatures if the correlation
between Patronus animals and animagus
forms is as concrete as we suspect then
we can logically deduce that it is
possible for the animagus form of
witches and wizards to resemble even the
mightiest of creatures like dragons
chimeras vestrals and phoenixes in the
books however we're only introduced to a
handful of more common animals like dogs
cats rats Etc this brings me to the
short list of known anime guy in the
series James Potter was the father of
Harry Potter and achieved the feat of
becoming an animagus at the age of 15.
his animagus form matched his corporeal
Patronus form which was a tall and
Powerful Red Stag Sirius Black was the
Godfather of Harry Potter like James
Sirius also accomplished this feat at
the age of 15. his animagus form
resembling a large black dog Peter
Pettigrew with the help of his fellow
Marauders was also able to become an
animagus Patrick's animagus form was a
rat which eventually earned him the
nickname of wormtail Rita Skeeter was a
journalist in which with a bit of a
dubious reputation for being dishonest
in her journalistic Endeavors Skeeter
used her unassum swimming and
unregistered animagus form of a Blue
Beetle to get dirt on whatever it was
that she was writing about Minerva
McGonagall Transfiguration Master had
the ability to transform into a silver
tabby cat she was known to use this
ability when she didn't want to be seen
or recognized Talbot Winger a Hogwarts
student from the 1980s was said to have
been able to transform into an eagle his
mother whose name we don't know was able
to turn into a swan and as far as known
anime guy are concerned that's about it
in the above list you may have noticed
me throwing around the terms registered
and unregistered what I'm referring to
here is whether or not these witches and
wizards have registered their animega
status with the ministry of magic let me
explain if you are able to successfully
transform into any kind of animagus form
Wizarding Lord dictates that you must
register this ability with the ministry
the following quote explains this we did
anime guy in class with Professor
McGonagall and I looked them up when I
did my homework the ministry of magic
keeps tabs on witches and wizards who
can become animals but to register
showing what animal they become and
their markings and things they went and
looked Professor McGonagall up on the
register and there have only been seven
anime guy this Century once you've
achieve this massive accomplishment the
registration is processed by an employee
and the improper use of magic office in
the ministry of magic it's not a
certification proving that you have the
skill but merely adding your specific
info to the ministry list so they can
keep tabs on you if needed if your
animagus status is unknown it gives you
a little bit too much flexibility to
just drop off the face of the Earth as
we saw with Peter Pettigrew but perhaps
the most surprising aspect of the above
passage is that according to Hermione's
research there are only seven known
anime guy from the last century what I
want to discuss further is why how is it
that this powerful ability is so
underutilized in Wizarding Society why
haven't powerful witches like Voldemort
and Dumbledore attempted it let's dive
in misreporting the first and simplest
answer to this question is that there
are many more anime guy in The Wizarding
World than we are led to believe I'd bet
money that there are dozens of witches
and wizards out there who achieved this
impressive feat and have simply decided
not to register themselves with the
ministry of Magic the primary function
of the registration system was to ensure
that anime guy did not abuse their
abilities but I imagine that existing as
a non-registered animagus would
undoubtedly come with many advantages
that most witches and wizards wouldn't
be so quick to relinquish but can you
blame them I feel like most of the
advantages gained from becoming an
animagus go straight out the window upon
registration the complex process the
next answer to this question is that for
some the drawn out intricate and
precarious process involved was becoming
an animagus simply may not be worth
pursuing the extensive process involved
with becoming an animagus has been
outlined on Pottermore step one do your
homework in Transfiguration and Potions
at least becoming an animagus requires a
witch or wizard to be skilled in both
these areas in order to stand a chance
of achieving such a complex
transformation
Step 2 carry a single Mandrake Leaf in
your mouth for an entire month from Full
Moon to Full Moon to be precise yes
we're serious if you swallow the leaf or
remove it from your mouth at any point
you have to start the whole thing again
no one likes to see that happen you then
have to find a small Crystal file that
receives the pure rays of the Moon put
your saliva filled Leaf inside and add
one of your own hairs step 3 add a
silver teaspoon of Jude from a place
that neither sunlight nor human feet
have touched for a full seven days and
if that wasn't hard enough you then have
to add the Chrysalis of a death's head
Hawk moth to the crystal file as well
then put this mixture in a quiet dark
place and leave it alone until the next
electrical storm and really leave it
alone don't even look at it don't even
think about looking at it step 4 while
waiting for the storm you must place
your wand tip over your heart every
sunrise and Sundown and speak the
following incantation Amato anime Mo and
Amato and omegas if you keep repeating
your incantation there will come a time
when with the touch of the one tip to
the chest a second heartbeat may be
sensed don't change anything keep going
keep waiting for that storm step 5 as
soon as lighting appears in the sky go
to the place where you've hidden your
Crystal file at last if you've done
everything right then you will discover
a mouthful of blood red potion inside it
then move somewhere but you aren't going
to alarm anyone or place yourself in
physical danger during your
transformation an animagus
transformation party is definitely a bad
idea step 6 place your want tip against
your heart and speak the incantation
Amato Animo animato and omegas and drink
the potion you will then feel fiery pain
lucky you and an intense double
heartbeat step 7 the shape of the
creature into which you will shortly
transform will appear in your mind the
instructions then warn you must show no
fear it is too late late now to escape
the change you have willed yikes step 8
when your transformation is complete you
are strongly advised to pick up your
wand and hide it somewhere safe so you
can find it post-transformation to
return to human form visualize your
human self as clearly as you can don't
worry if you don't change back
immediately with practice you'll be able
to slip in and out of your animal form
at well simply by visualizing the
creature once you're an advanced
animagus you should be able to transform
without your wand and if these extremely
particular and time-consuming
instructions still weren't enough to put
you off the process then surely the next
point will it's dangerous becoming an
animagus involves significant risks if
the process is not executed correctly
the consequences can be disastrous this
is also outlined on Pottermore when the
process of becoming animagus goes wrong
it often goes seriously wrong we're
talking horrible half human half animal
mutations here with no known cure the
First Transformation is usually
uncomfortable and frightening clothing
and item such as glasses or jewelry melt
the skin and become one with fur scales
or spikes when you first transform try
to avoid panicking otherwise the animal
mind May gain the ascendancy and you
could do something stupid or dangerous
difficulty the final reason that
becoming an animagus isn't for everyone
simply boils down to the fact that it's
very difficult not only do you need the
mental fortitude to look past all of the
aforementioned complications you also
need to be extremely talented in the
field of transfiguration while
Transfiguration is a core subject taught
at Hogwarts the ability to become an
animagus is a rare and advanced skill
that few witches and wizards are capable
of achieving anime guy Transformations
demonstrate the incredible potential of
transfiguration magic and the Mastery
required to achieve such a feat is a
testament to the magical prowess of
those who are able to do so in summary
the apparent shortage of witches and
wizards capable of becoming anime guy is
a direct result of the complexity risk
and commitment involved in the process
of becoming one however I also believe
that we should be taking the ministry
figures for anime guy with a grain of
salt though ran complicated I don't
think it's nearly as rare as what we're
led to believe more than likely there
are copious powerful Wizards out there
like I don't know Voldemort and
Dumbledore for example that have
mastered the ability but have simply
never chosen to reveal it and that's it
for this video what do you think did
this question ever occur to you leave a
comment down below also if you enjoy the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live